as well
here he is
the migrants and everybody who's working
in the hospital in calais people from
the prefecture who are carrying on
trying to deal with this drama
so what happened today
to our knowledge of 33 people
their
days are numbered amongst the 33 dead
they're
as far as we know five women and a
little girl
we don't have any more information
with regard to those people of course
one will carry on searching for them in
the hours that come to see if there
aren't any other people
today
just during the
[Music]
day between the fat gallery and the
northern zone
there were 580 chandan
who were looking at the
beaches along the coast
and there were 255 people who succeeded
in getting to the other side of channel
but 671
who were stopped
and stopped from going through
so therefore we're talking about a day
like any other day of the migrants who
are spending a few hours a few days a
few weeks
on our territory and who want to go to
england
at their risk in peril and uh often like
today we can see these appalling dramas
i would also like to say that those who
are initially responsible for the
situation the passers in other words
criminals who go for a few thousand
euros organize human trafficking from
iraq from afghanistan from africa from
asia and who then use these people
they make them come
from to belgium to holland and
specifically to france to
cross the channel and to go to the
united kingdom and it's those people we
have to fight against there are 1 500
that have been arrested since the first
of january and four of them today we
suspect that they were directly linked
to that particular
embarkation and two of them were
arrested
from the 1st of january
800 migrants were saved at sea by
sailors and i'd like to thank the
national
marine
and the uh army for having helped by the
uh maritime champion by the police
office by the chandan by the
people who've saved them who also
are intervening and their lives are
apparel also to try to save these men
and women 7 800 lives that we've saved
of course our victory here but today
it's an appalling situation for france
for europe and for humanity to see these
people perish at sea because of these
traffickers
and i would also like to say that we
enormously
pre-appreciate her the mayor of galera
and everybody who along the coast has
been undergoing this situation for far
too long and here today we've still got
really work with the president of the
republic and the prime minister to try
to improve their lives and to try to
stop these uh
embarkations with our german friends as
well because uh the zodiacs often are
bored with dinghy support in germany
and we want the german government to
stop that and our belgian
colleagues because 60 percent who are in
galilee
come from belgium
and of course uh british opposite
numbers with whom i'm almost
in relation every day and i would also
like to say that
the means that we used today
were very important there were three uh
ships uh two helicopters uh
a british helicopter a french helicopter
and of course dozens of people who are
risking their life to try to save these
lives
are you sure that all the victims were
on one invocation i can't tell you
all i know is that uh according to the
national marine
the uh
dinghy that they
there were 30 of them
there's possibly still one person that
we're looking for but we can't confirm
that piece of information but it was a
very frail very
embarkation and when the people came to
save them
that uh ship or dinghy was kind of
completely
like it was like a pool that you blow up
on in your garden
so it was possibly just one embarkation
but
dozens of
migrants try to cross the channel in
the very cold sea
it's almost uh the greatest
most aware because there are so many
ships
between the dutch ports
and the other port so therefore it's
very possible
that it was just one embarkation
with all these people
we've
never encountered such a
catastrophe in the past
over the past 20 years
what's your reaction
don't you feel a bit responsible
nevertheless
there's always
responsibility but the first
responsibility is that of the criminals
or traffickers and of course
this really touched us but we're also
very upset but we're also furious as far
as these traffic is concerned and also
as far as other countries that are not
entirely playing the game as far as the
interception of these criminals they
have to be treated like criminals
because after all they resembled
terrorists they traffic drugs
and
today they are playing with the lives of
pregnant women
and
and sometimes babies as well
and of course it's an extraordinary
drama
and it's certainly
we have to be able to respond the police
the justice system and we have to have
extra means to be able to deal with it
and not only the french people we can
see that it's an international problem
we can see that the ships are bought far
away often in fact they
get aboard and get into lorries four or
five hundred kilometers away and they
wait for daisy things in canada or
dunkirk
and uh of course
without international intelligence to
see whether traffickers are in the uk
and belgium in germany elsewhere we
won't be able to fight against these
criminals
and i also want to say
that of course
it is a major drama
of course there are other dramas
as you know that there have been seven
that disappeared but every day some
charleston police officers risking their
lives to try to save these people
because i remind you there was seven
thousand uh 100 to try to get over since
first of january so first of all my
first emotion is fury and tomorrow
morning with the prime minister and the
minister's meeting and with the
president of the republic uh we will
submit some new proposals as far as
means we can use to try to dismantle
these networks
and what about the uk
well of course uk's also got to uh
respond uh three days ago i had an
exchange with pretty patel the uh
to see what means the uk will give
france
and of course more police officers more
cameras
more gender
we have to work together two major
countries who are friends we have to
fight against these traffickers together
and they play on our borders
sadly our differences of legislation
sometimes mean that there's a slight
lack of cooperation
and so therefore
i also mentioned this to the minister a
few days ago of course we didn't know
that this would happen today but uh i
sent her a list from the judicial police
to try to
improve response and improve the
response from our government
and we want to ensure it's an
international coordinated tough response
and we have to make sure that this
appalling drama
stops further drivers and france is
certainly putting in
great means as far as this fight against
clandestine immigration
imagine seven thousand
780 police officers were involved today
and we're talking about of course winter
time but this can only be done in
belgium germany
holland and uk work all together
possibly we're not working together
enough yet but we really must fight
against these criminals that'll be fight
against terrorists
are you trying to
find some other people at the moment
well there are two people that have been
saved
that were
[Music]
but their lives are
in danger they've got hypothermia
but i don't think that there's
possibility of finding other survivors
of course a national
marine is still carrying out its work
so there are two people that have been
saved and 33 who died to my knowledge
and of course
we don't have all the details
but 34 people had embarked
33 were found
two
so there's still one person that's uh
disappeared
what nationality
we don't yet know the nationality of
these people
because of course uh we don't have any
documents of course
and uh the people being looked after
today
of course are in intensive care so we
can't
interrogate them thank you very much